Fabiano you had a full night to sit on
this result how impactful is this
national championship for
you yeah it's it's always very special
for me uh to to win the US championship
and it's been very difficult in the past
for me uh I I went many years without
being able to break through and last
year things went smoothly this year as
well so it's uh it's very important for
me both from the point of view of uh how
strong of a tournament it is and also so
from a personal point of view because it
is the US championship did you take any
lessons from last year's championship uh
Victory into this year's
championship I thought that it felt
similar to last year in the sense that
nobody is really trying making like huge
strides towards um like there are some
years where people start to run away
with it for example I can recall in 2018
uh I had a good event but Sam shankland
went plus six and there was no way for
me to catch up at the end
uh despite my best efforts and but I
think also chess in general these days
it's harder to uh to get a
win uh it just seems like the level of
play in general the level of preparation
is so high for people that you you see
everyone struggling to create chances or
um sometimes they do but it's because
you unexpectedly get chances during the
game like those those kind of clinical
displays that used to be very common
where you get an advantage from the
opening you increase the pressure and
you win are exceedingly rare these days
so uh of course it's uh it's really uh
really huge for me that I I was able to
do it this time because I I know that
these tournament victories don't come
easily and I know it from experience and
and these days it gets more and more
difficult especially with the young guys
getting stronger and and they're super
motivated so uh you you have to put a
huge amount of effort into these types
of events guys any questions for our
champion absolutely I have one question
first of all congratulations great
performance what would you say is your
favorite game of this
tournament
um it's kind of hard to say I would say
the the game which I recall most fondly
is the game against Hans because that
was pretty much the game that um I
really needed to win to to keep up when
when lenier and Wesley they were they
were picking up wins near the end I
needed to to keep that Gap so that was
super
important in terms wins like I don't
feel I played a super beautiful game in
any any of the games um like generally
speaking I played some decent games with
nothing that I can recall as like um
going to be super memorable but yeah
that maybe that game against Hans
and uh like the most important game I
feel is the game against daro I think
that was that was really important for
my tournament because if I had drawn
that game and and it seemed for a long
time that I had no chances to win the
entire game pretty much
I I don't think that it would have gone
as smoothly in the remainder of the
event so that that game I look back as
maybe the like most the most essential
moments in the tournament because
sometimes it's about just like playing a
really long game and waiting for that
opponent to make a mistake yeah Bobby I
also without my uh admiration and
congratulations for your Victory uh your
key rival uh Wesley so he came on the
show and he said you know if there was
only one time control in chess I could
focus on it and I feel like I could be
perform better uh and he mentioned
specifically you uh that you have
improved uh you you you've had a very
good
2023 uh you've you you uh and the
candidates again you've won the uh
back-to-back US championships in Norway
you were simply excellent but you've
also improved your Blitz and your online
Speed play and and he almost openly
asked how how does he do it how do you
get better at at Blitz as well as uh
classical normally you focus on one or
the
other well I think that chess is chess
so any sort of Chess work will will uh
improve your results in any area of the
game MH uh I do I do understand his
point that it's difficult to constantly
be readjusting to the different time
controls if I could give Wesley any one
piece of advice I would say that it
helps to take up podcasting that's
that's the one thing I would say I'm
looking forward to the to the Wesley
podcast someday all right very good
Bobby uh what can we say just tip of the
Hat well done and uh keep up the great
work I know the sville cup is coming up
for you so uh you still have a lot more
challenges this year ahead of you good
luck thank you absolutely and the 2020
the US champion Grand Master Fabiano
caruana absolutely uh very very well
done indeed and uh undefeated again